As a giant scale service provider, another
thing that the service provider has to
worry about is online evolution and growth
of the service. because services are evolving continuously.
The Gmail that you're accessing for getting your email today may not be the same
that you accessed a month back. So,
since the services are continuously evolving, the servers
at the data centers have to be upgraded with
a new version of the software or maybe new nodes
are being added, or maybe all the old nodes
are being retired, and brand-new nodes are being brought in
to serve the user community. Whether it is hardware
or software upgrade that needs to be done, that has
to be done with the understanding that while that upgrade
is happening, there is going to be loss of service.
Again the DQ principal comes in handy in measuring what exactly is the loss
that we're observing of the service when we do this kind of online evolution and
growth. The first choice, is what is called fast reboot. That is, bring down all
the servers at once, upgrade them, and then turn them back on. So this diagram
is showing you, time on the x axis, and the loss, DQ loss, on the y axis,
and what you're seeing here, this is the
time for the upgrade per node. So the amount
of time a node is going to be down in order to do that upgrade, whether it is
a software upgrade or a hardware upgrade. And this
y axis segment is the DQ loss per node.
So if I bring down a node and upgrade
it, it's going to be down for some amount of time.
And this is the amount of server capacity that is
lost, the DQ that is lost, as a result of
one server being down. If all the servers are
down, which is what is happening with fast reboot, then
for this entire time, the area bounded by this green-shaded
rectangle, we're going to have no service. The ideal is here
in terms of the total amount of DQ we want, and the access is saying how much is
the DQ that is lost and what we are saying is, if we do this fast reboot, that
fast reboot is going to bring all the servers down
for a certain amount of time that it takes
to upgrade them, and for the entire duration, the
service is unavailable. This idea of fast reboot is
particularly useful in situations where we can use
diurnal server property. For instance, if you think
about services that are being all across the
globe. We can use factors such as oh, this
is nighttime for the user community and the
users have probably gone night-night and therefore, they are
not going to access the servers. This is a
good time to bring down the whole service and
upgrade the service. So that might be a situation where fast reboot is very
useful. So we are assuming that the user community is segmented so that they're
directed to geographically different locations, and we
can use the diurnal server property to
do this off-peak fast reboot of chosen replicas of the services. In this figure,
so in this figure this segment that I'm
showing you here is the DQ loss per node.
And the total DQ losses, of course, n times
DQ, where n is a number of servers that
are undergoing this fast reboot. So in other
words, for u units of time, there is complete
loss of DQ with fast reboot. An alternative to
fast reboot is what is called a rolling upgrade.
Now here, what we're doing is, rather than bring
all the servers down at the same time, we
are bringing one server down at a time. And
upgrading one server, bringing down the next server, upgrading
it, and so on. This is what is called
rolling upgrade or wave upgrade. And in this case,
services available all throughout, there is no time that
we are saying that the service is completely unavailable.
But, for the entire duration of time, the duration of time here is n times
u, because u is the upgrade time per node, and the upgrade, because it is a wave
upgrade, is going to last for n times u time units, where n is a number of
servers being upgraded in this fashion. But during
the entire time, service is available, but in
every u units of time, there's a DQ loss of
this much bounded by this area during the entire upgrade process.